make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
so the talk of the town at the moment
and in all honesty I was gonna record
this in the c200 but I didn't feel like
recording it and bringing it downstairs
then color correcting and editing and
all that kind of stuff sometimes
recording this just straight vocal audio
um the talk of the town is is what like
who Keanu Reeves is going to play in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe right because
Kevin Feige and all them have been like
we're trying to find a way to work him
in and it is kind of cool to see that
that like Keanu Reeves is going to
appear and like the the Marvel Cinematic
Universe there were a couple ideas on
who I thought he should play the first
and most obvious character for him to
play is the one above all because he
looks just like him right if you go
check out sensational spider-man number
forty I think it is you end up seeing
the one above all meeting Peter Parker
now the the entire basis behind
sensational spider-man number forty is
that this was a story where Aunt May was
basically dying and the result was that
Peter was having a hard time coming to
grips with it and then like he's visited
by the one above all who takes the
presence of a homeless man now the
reason why is because like I mean when
you look at Keanu Reeves he looks
exactly like the one above all in that
story which I guess it kind of begs a
question why does Keanu Reeves look like
a homeless man but the fact remains here
that like just in terms of physical
appearance it works the problem with
this is that while Stanley has never
really been confirmed by Kevin Feige and
all them to actually be the one above
all for the most part fans have kind of
run with it and there's this kind of
unwritten rule when it comes to like
comic book movies or like fan
perceptions of things that when fans
sort of latch on to an idea they kind of
make it a rule even though it's not and
so in turn like anything that goes
against that is really kind of
considered to be condemned right and so
if the result is that if really the
movie-going audience and the comic book
fans as a whole myself included who did
kind of look at Stanley and say okay if
I am them in 2017 or whatever in their
interview with screen junkies or screen
ran or one of the screen channels if he
did an interview and said well Stanley
plays the same character across all the
cameos that he's ever been in but they
never explicitly said he's the one above
all and fans was kind of like but I mean
he pretty much is though then like that
becomes a standard right it's just kind
of accepted to be that way and so
throwing Keanu Reeves into the Marvel
Cinematic Universe as the one above all
is a dangerous game to play because what
it could do is turn into like the first
huge flop of the Marvel Cinematic
Universe
that's totally rejected by the
movie-going audience and fans because
it's not what they want they want Stan
Lee to be the one above all because a
lot of people and I would probably you
know consider myself in this group a lot
of people might consider it to be like a
little disrespectful of Stan Lee's
memory and Marvel Comics the one above
all is like the creator of all things in
existence
right I mean it's this immutable
indestructible undefeatable force right
like nothing can defeat the one above
all not even the beyonders we'll talk
about them here in a minute and because
of that it would make sense that like
the man who really helped to co-create
all these characters who exists short of
really just like Captain America odd
that when he passes on he would kind of
get a tribute it's like yes Stanley's
the one above all you know he created
all these these comic book characters it
makes sense that he's the one that
created everything in existence in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe right just
kind of a great way a nice little
send-off in a way to kind of respect the
memory of Stanley and all the things
that he's done but again it's not an
absolute rule it's not a hard-and-fast
rule because it's not actually been
confirmed by anybody yet and so from
there the question becomes who do you
make Keanu Reeves if you're not going to
make him the one above all well the
answer that question is the Beyonder
like literally you have a voice to
beyond earth and the reason why is
because we know the Russo brothers want
to do Secret Wars right so like if the
Dioner is going to appear as part of
seeker wars have Keanu Reeves Keanu
Reeves be the voice of them I think it
makes more sense and the reason why is
because neo for Keanu Reeves to maintain
longevity in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe he cannot play a particular
character we've seen that unfold in like
the MCU as it exists so far right like
you know those of you guys who haven't
seen Avengers in game I don't know
anybody who hasn't seen it yet but like
spoilers for Avengers in game the most
successful movie in the history of the
world Iron Man dies spoiler alert Iron
Man dies like he's out of the picture
now right because Tony like like Robert
Downey jr. cannot play the character
forever because he ages in real life
there's no like comics where they can
just keep drawing in the same way or
until like the end of time he ages in
real life
Captain America has aged up and he's out
of the picture now at least Steve Rogers
is and and Falcons taking over the
mantle because we're talking about
characters like actors who age in real
time their characters will age out and
they'll be replaced by new ones Keanu
Reeves would be the exact same way this
is doubly more complex if you make him a
god right like if you make him like Zeus
and in the Greek mythology in Marvel
Comics and he alongside Odin and a
handful of others or like the sky
fathers and so on and so forth there
comes a time when like he has to go
which becomes a question like how do you
explain the death of Zeus it's a god he
doesn't age like he's immortal he'll
live forever that's the kind of problem
you run into and so with an actor like
Keanu Reeves because he's so cool he's
so interesting his voice is so calm and
relaxed what you need is for him to
voice a character that's so immensely
powerful he doesn't really get angry or
anything like that there's no reason for
him to write I mean the only people
really get like up in arms and angry are
basically individuals who kind of feel
out of control but like a person who's
in control has no reason to get
set because nothing's happening that
they do not want to happen and so when
you look at the character of the
Beyonder in Marvel Comics is really
really intriguing so the way this plays
out is you have what are called cosmic
cubes and cosmic cubes are basically
these cube shaped artifacts you know a
square in a three-dimensional space that
basically takes energy from the beyond
verse right like this this place outside
of the multiverse that houses these
beings called the beyonders who are just
insanely powerful they're they were
powerful enough to destroy the Living
Tribunal to like wipe him out in the
span of like few minutes but basically
it takes energy from that realm and it
siphons it into the main Marvel Universe
and contains it inside of a cube that's
the way that's supposed to happen right
like the scrolls were the first ones to
do it
after the scrolls came advanced idea
mechanics which are basically the
scientific arm of Hydra on all that kind
of kind of you know happen in a linear
progression but what ended up taking
place is that you had this guy named uh
named Owen Reese who is performing this
experiment and accidentally opened up a
hole to the beyond verse not realizing
what he did but there was no containment
there was no cosmic cube for that energy
to flow into and so the result was that
half the energy went into him and then
half the energy just kind of floated out
there in the cosmos and eventually
became sentient in the form of the
Beyonder when it became since he at the
beyond it was basically like a child it
was curious and so looking around the
universe it basically saw heroes and
villains right the good guys and the bad
guys and so curious to see who would win
the Beyonder
pit the two groups against each other
and the Beyonder had basically created
like battle world creel took these
little bits and pieces of different
places around the universe pieces of
earth pieces of other planets and things
like that and form them into a singular
planet and instead like I am from beyond
you all have to fight each other whoever
wins I will grant their wildest dream
whatever it happens to be but it was
just curious it was like who would win
between all the heroes and all the
villains that was a story called seeker
wars and so with that with that taking
place it would be kind of a cool way for
Keanu Reeves to exist in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe and he could actually
be there indefinitely because that was
not the first time the Beyonder showed
up but it wasn't the only time or at
least it was the first time it was not
the only time
the Beyonder came back in Secret Wars
too and in the Beyonder return in the
unofficial Secret Wars 3 which was
actually a Fantastic Four story offer
back in the day but like the Beyonder
could show up almost any number of times
and could actually just kind of reside
on earth there's a lot of ways that you
could do that the issue is to be honors
kind of a one-trick pony you introduce
him they do some fighting some stuff
happens and then the story's done and
that's basically yet but if they wanted
to bring him back they could and that's
why I think Keanu Reeves would work for
that character because Canterbury's has
the voice for and now a lot of other
people
do but what you need with a character
with with Keanu Reeves in the MCU is you
need him to play a character that's
basically someone who is insanely
powerful and someone that seems like
they're not to be trifled with right
kind of playing on the whole John Blake
theme they're like he's this guy where
his kinda like man they beat this guy up
and they killed his dog and they stole
his cart man it sucks to be him didn't
you find out he's like the greatest
assassin in the world and it's like dude
those guys are all gonna die and I
cannot wait to watch it happen because
screw those guys they killed a puppy you
need a character who's just like that
super that that's just like that's super
powerful because the voice of Keanu
Reeves comes off as hey I don't really
care how things unfold I'm really just
more curious than anything else that's
the kind of voice he has that you can
apply to the Marvel Cinematic Universe
now outside of that there are a couple
other characters that that Reeves could
play and I think actually play pretty
well if we were gonna have him move away
from voicing a character and play an
actual character on screen I'd have him
play Gabriel Shepherd and I think he'd
be amazing but here's what I think a lot
of people don't know who Gabriel Shepard
is but what if I told you there was a
mutant out there who was godly powerful
and who's only appeared like six times
right in like a single story up do you
have the mutants right like like the
x-men the issue here is that when it
comes to the X gene it took time to get
to the current state of things right so
you basically have like like the the
Celestials who showed up on earth they
mess with the genes of people so you had
like the Eternals who basically went
forward as like angelic beings you had
the deviants who resided underground and
then you had like baseline humans whose
genes whose Xchange would manifest
somewhere along the line the first
person to Heather their X gene manifest
was Selene some like ten thousand years
ago after that you've had a pocalypse
which is about five thousand years ago
and then you had like one or two other
people then you have this gap where
nothing happened and then you run into
like six or seven hundred years ago and
then there's like these handful of proto
mutants who were basically you basically
live in Crimea and the the basis behind
this is that proto mutants had a less
evolved X gene much like further X gene
we're not was not on par with like
modern-day mutants the only exception to
that was a guy named Gabriel Shepherd
where all the proto mutants were
essentially killed off as a result of a
black plague and the belief of humans
living in the region that the proto
mutants were the reason for it Gabriel
Shepard managed to survive and this guy
can do everything this guy has all your
standard run-of-the-mill powers right so
like superhuman strength speed
durability but he's actually immortal he
can basically create like time pockets
he can control like the very fabric of
the universe he's got telepathy
he's got like superhuman acute sentences
since he's got like a healing factor um
he can actually like leave his his
physical form and achieve kind of like a
pure psychic energy form I mean this guy
could do all kinds of crazy stuff but
he's only ever appeared in a small
number of comics now the results of this
is that when it comes to a character
like him with him basically being
immortal that would mean that if the MCU
introduced him in as his Marvel Comics
counterpart he would live forever
introduce him in is like the missing
link between when the Eternals first
brought in and first like modify the
genes of baseline humans to give the
mutant powers and then between like the
time that happened and like the modern
day when the x-men pop up you have
Gabriel Shepard who is one of the first
beings to manifest mutant powers if it
only took him seven hundred years to
harness them and figure out how to use
them but again like there's a lot of
things that you could do there with
Keanu Reeves in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe again my pick is Gabriel
Shepard but they decided to go that
route you could do moon night that's a
really good choice is a really popular
theory circulating around right now I've
got my own theory on who I think should
play Moon Knight and I do not believe is
Keanu Reeves but nonetheless it's a cool
idea
there's a lot of things that you could
do with it with a guy like this because
after watching the John wick movies it's
obvious he can do like an action-packed
role right like he can move around and
the fact that the character of John wick
was so rooted in in like reality meaning
he wasn't doing like crazy acrobatic
things he did a couple somersaults
rolled around a little bit and shot
everybody in the head you can kind of
take that concept and throw it into the
MCU which is very similar in terms of
more grounded characters the world
outside your window so to speak and then
to sort of throw Keanu Reeves in
accordingly but regardless I'm curious
who do you guys think you should play
I'm curious who you think he on a
rishaad play in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe what was it being said we're
gonna bring this video to an end if you
are new here to come this explain make
sure you guys at the sub button to
become part of the Rob core if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like and I will catch you all later
peace
[Music]